oh I'm just living the dream onna hey
Adina we can't imagine anyone else
voicing Elsa your vocals literally bring
the ice princess to life and your cool
stars do an amazing job - oh I'm just
living the dream ah ah oh how I wish
this could last forever without the
entire cast of frozen - the sequel just
wouldn't be the same but let's face it
you didn't become the queen of Broadway
without respecting your fair share of
rules if you or any of the other cast
members disrespect the rules set out for
you you could lose your roles and
disappoint a lot of fans so we're happy
you guys took the rulebook seriously the
life of a voice actor may seem pretty
straightforward but it's a lot more
challenging than it seems the entire
cast of frozen 2 was given a long list
of strict rules that they had to follow
no ifs ands or buts keep watching till
the end to find out which rule keeps
these actors on lockdown she seems like
Elsa watch what you do and say if
there's one rule every voice actor lives
by it's to always be on the game and the
Casta frozen to is no exception
at any moment fans and reporters can ask
them questions and they need to know
what they can and cannot answer the last
thing voice actors want is to get
tricked into revealing too much about
their upcoming films because well that
would be a huge contract violation
keeping the plot of frozen 2 under wraps
was the cast primary concern but not
their only one on top of keeping their
lips sealed the actors had to be on
their best behavior
since frozen 2 has a relatively young
following idina menzel Kristen Bell and
the entire crew have to protect your
image if they make headlines for all the
wrong reasons Disney executives will
come knocking and that's never a good
thing
scandals and spoilers are simply not
permitted luckily the entire cast was
able to retain their stellar reputations
I'm coming me too I'll Drive I'll
represent your character you would think
that voice actors spend most of their
time in the recording studio but that
just isn't the case especially not with
a high-profile movie like frozen zoo
while secondary characters like Grandpa
be Ryder Elena and honey Marin aren't
required to attend major events the main
cast is 100% of the time
jonathan groff josh grad Kristen Bell
Idina Menzel have a lengthy contract
that obligates them to attend press
releases and social events no matter
what continent they're on so on top of
spending
a lot of time in the studio these actors
are required to travel and deliver
plenty of face time but most of them
don't mind the hectic schedules as it
helps promote the movie while allowing
them to wear designer clothing to
red-carpet events chime in to properly
voice an animated character you have to
become that character inside and out and
the more voice actors connect with their
characters the more believable their
performances will be what a bond is
finally formed these actors can start
chiming in and giving producers ideas
which is sort of expected of them
Disney producers and writers consulted
with the voice actors of frozen - they
wanted their opinions and feedback on
storylines and character arcs but they
also wanted their ideas since no one
knows that character is more than the
actors who play them it's pretty much
required for the cast to chime in
especially when dealing with sequels
creative brainstorming might not be part
of the job description but it's a small
price to pay for voicing household names
like Elsa Anna Kristoff and Olaf here at
the things we love posting videos about
the latest Disney films like frozen
- if you loved Theory videos don't
forget to subscribe and enable post
notifications this way you can be the
first to comment on our latest videos if
you're tuning in on your mobile turn on
post notifications on your YouTube
settings
clear your schedule anyone who has
worked for Disney knows how challenging
it can be to create a flawless
storyboard they basically don't exist
and plots and scripts are constantly
changing as new ideas get introduced a
voice actor can spend days rehearsing
for a certain scene only to have it cut
unicorn ice cream castle oaken teapot
and they can be given a day off after
long hours in the studio only to be
called in because a new scene was just
introduced the cast of frozen - had to
clear their schedules in case they were
asked back to the studio for another
round of recording and in case of a
sequel three cool or spin-offs these
actors also have to be aware of
accepting new projects they're legally
obliged to voice their characters so
when Disney calls they have no choice
but to answer of your life protect your
voice a voice actors worst fear is
getting sick and they're expected to do
everything to stop this
happening from wearing a scarf to
constantly drinking warm liquids to
staying in when the weather gets bad all
of this and more is expected of them the
cast of frozen - did everything in their
power to stay healthy while filming
frozen - can you imagine Elsa singing
into the unknown with a raspy voice
well neither can we I belong here alone
and that's a wrap on the five strict
rules the voice actors of frozen - had
to follow which rule surprised you the
most tell us in the comments
[Music]